welcome to this video l phenomenal elfin
no no the UK no I never played that guy
before okay let's see classical Kings
Indian probably yeah he got that one
yeah night bt7 that's a pretty old line
but it's not that bad rookie adium
that's an interesting way to play that
no one like normally goes Knight h5 I
believe night age five and g3 bishop and
six or something like that yeah it's
kind of weird but but not that bad okay
yeah mama Bishop g5 not clear that it is
said that great but still if I can
prevent that I probably should do it
okay just f3 not totally clear on that
he didn't threaten much maybe to Jake
not at five but ok this looks that looks
ok he cannot easily play f4
now that's a that's an okay position wyd
always has the space and that's not
going to change anytime soon okay so he
basically says if I take here it's not a
big deal Joakim allowing f4 is not a
great idea I wonder I'm sorry I wonder
if in this position how important the
dark squared Bishop really is or if I
should just go nitey form yeah let's do
that normally it's kind of an almost a
knee-jerk reaction to preserve the
bishop here the dark squared bishop on
the white side of the Kings Indian I'm
not sure here his bishop is really not
doing much and maybe the light squared
control here is actually more important
the bishop on f2 is blocking a possible
night to f2 so aha very that's a very
creative way to play it interesting okay
yeah i mean i don't really see why I
shouldn't take it well yeah it was kind
of clear but is it really is it really
that that much of an issue I can hmm now
that's okay covering g-form and
attending to take an idea for what I
have absolutely have to prevent is some
kind of Bishop coming to D for this kind
of thing here's some dark squared Bishop
invading my macam this has to be
prevented
at almost all costs so I'm just doubling
no one DF file right keep it simple I
mean why it is pretty much a pawn up
slow no particular compensation at least
I don't see any okay can just take them
on why improve the position a little bit
now i see no direct benefit from taking
I can play other things and I can even
play h4 h4 g5 push and push forward yeah
that was to be that was expected I was
just thinking or expected is wrong I
mean I thought about that but I thought
that I can just take a seven now
actually why not I mean I have got
everything covered him bishop coming to
h6 but it's not that's not that much of
a deal anymore now with all the pieces
traded so why shouldn't I take the Queen
side here the 87 pawn yeah so we had to
had to play a passive defense okay
nothing wrong with age three so let's
say he takes everything there and at the
end i play i start with Queen f2 where
we take everything then Queen f3 Queen
g6 g4l that sets okay it's total control
don't need don't need anything anything
wrong
yeah I had this position in mind here he
has no yeah no way really to to muddy
the waters yeah he have G form and then
Queen h3 Queen at five this kind of
thing Queen trade is basically the same
sm as a win Queen f5 or what is the
right one Queen five if he goes Queen h6
I have nice g5 yo that should be enough
yeah okay OS them can also give the
check here for night e 6 that it's also
win okay Jack it's probably them check
the cleanest one with them with a total
trade of everything to the king and porn
and game how can I win the bishop maybe
with g5g five Queen g6 right da check
your time morning why not
yeah I'm just just taking everything on
g7 this was the winning team porn in
game check but winning the queen is also
quite okay yeah I think that this man
design this g4 pawn sacrifice it wasn't
really working I think yeah an
interesting moment was when you went G
hive and um yeah I don't know I took on
f5 basically intending to give up the
dark squared Bishop but here there are
many options this is also possible of
course I didn't it wasn't so sure about
this kind of thing I mean okay my pieces
are all right for the Queen side but
what about Bishop is free business and
things like that the computer is
actually very very convinced that that
should be almost winning for white hmm
hmm in Kings Indian structures I'm a bit
skeptical but I admit that it looks very
nice i mean i have gotten i don't know
how many tempe here but ok i rather
that's my decision just get a clear
structure yeah giving up the dark
squared bishop as mentioned is always a
little bit of a risky business as the
dark squares are potentially week now a
piece on d4 okay well Bishop here would
win the queen but every in general some
peace appearing on the dark squares but
it's not so easy maybe the computer
wants to go see six giving why the
slight edge this is kind of what I
expected but I think this just gives it
away I mean it's just a pawn really and
we trade begin to trade things on the F
house so there is absolutely absolutely
no compensate
I think Jim check check the rtm okay I
don't need to return this pawn but this
is a very simple solution we get this
off Queen a 3g for and and that's it I
get to f5 possibly 95 what the Queen
trade and the Queen trade is the same as
since resigning actually yeah so this
was a pretty clean when I believe he am
yam he simply cannot play this Chi form
if he plays them if we just go back here
yes to play something like that I mean
it kind of doesn't fit together right I
mean why do you play g5 when when you
play c6 later I mean it kind of doesn't
add up this story but something like
that it probably has to try okay well
thanks for watching